[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando fue la última vez que te
detuviste leer las flores
has observado alguna vez cómo te sientes
cuando estás en un lugar y hay flores
naturales
sea un hotel un restaurant una casa una
oficina yo me acuerdo el día que mi papá
se dio cuenta que no había flores en la
casa y es que yo acostumbraba a cada
semana llevarles un ramo de flores a mis
papás y por alguna razón dejé de hacerlo
y mi mamá dejó de poner flores en la
sala de su casa y entonces pasaron como
tres días y un día llega mi papá y le
dice oye porque ya no hay flores
a raíz de ese comentario que yo empecé a
observar y prestar atención a los
efectos inconscientes que las flores
tienen en la vida de las personas y es
que mi mamá creía que mi papá ni le iba
ni le venía el hecho de que tuviera
flores
pero ese día nos dimos cuenta que si les
veía que si gustaban y además que el día
que no estuvieron le hicieron falta
entonces yo empecé a prestar atención
detallada a cómo se siente estar en un
lugar donde hay flores y qué le pasa a
las personas que entran en contacto con
ellas
lo primero que descubrí es que las
flores nos hacen sonreír
y es que yo no sabía pero cuando
sonreímos producimos serotonina que es
la hormona de la felicidad y también
aprendí que la felicidad que brota del
interior de una persona esa alegría
pues con razón siento tan feliz cuando
estoy con flores y es que yo comienzo a
sonreír desde que llego a comprarlas
mi parte favorita son los cambios de
estaciones llegar en primavera y toparte
con ranúnculos dalias en el verano
crisantemos ocres en el otoño y amarilis
en el invierno es realmente hermoso
y es que hay tantas formas tantos
colores tantos tamaños hay para todos y
no porque a mí me guste más una flor
quiere decir que yo estoy bien y tú
estás mal
aprender a disfrutar con alegría la
diversidad de flores que veo en la
naturaleza me ha enseñado también a
disfrutar con alegría la diversidad de
personas con que me topo todos los días
otra cosa que aprendí es que una de las
características más importantes de la
alegría es que es una energía en
movimiento si fuera una energía estática
no fuera capaz de producir ninguna
emoción en nosotros
6 donde las flores juegan un papel muy
importante
ponte en la sala de tu casa seguro
tienes algunos adornos
y de alguna manera ya se han convertido
en parte del inmueble pasas en
automático sin voltearlo saber
en cambio cuando tienes flores naturales
se pone en movimiento la energía es
inevitable no pasar voltear y además
sonreír
y es que las flores cambian todos los
días poder disfrutar un botón que
lentamente se va convirtiendo en una
hermosa flor es un verdadero deleite
además una vez que tienes flores en tu
vida el tiempo deja de pasar volando
cuando puedes traer las estaciones del
año al interior de tu vivienda de pausas
te detienes y disfrutas el presente
me di cuenta que las flores más allá de
decorar y hacer bonito un espacio
verdaderamente llenan de alegría a
nuestras vidas
y entonces con todo esto que fui
aprendiendo y observando comencé a
preguntarme por qué es que más personas
no han adoptado la cultura de siempre
tener flores como parte de su decoración
lo primero que descubrí es que la
mayoría de las personas les tienen miedo
creen que no duran mucho que son
frágiles que necesita ser muy creativo
para disfrutarlas o que es una inversión
cara
no dejo de sorprenderme cada que alguien
llegue me comenta que no compra flores
naturales porque se mueren y entonces
prefieren flores artificiales y no es
que tengan nada en contra de las flores
artificiales pero como les dije se
convierten en un adorno más de su casa
cuando tienes flores naturales aprendes
a disfrutar las cosas el tiempo que les
toca estar dejas de desear que las cosas
duren para siempre
hubo un día que fui a comprar unas
flores y me topé con unas alias hermosas
sabiendo que las dalias son flores
frágiles que duran muy poquito tiempo y
que además yo no tenía uso para ellas
estuve tentada a no comprarlas pero qué
bueno que sí lo hice no saben que tan
feliz fui y qué tan bonita se veían en
la sala de mi casa pero no sólo eso me
di cuenta que cuando tienes flores te
estás dando un regalo de ti para ti es
un acto de amor propio
además cuando se marchitaron y estaba
desbaratando me adorno floral me puse a
pensar en todas las veces que he dejado
de disfrutar el presente
añorando que el pasado hubiera durado
más tiempo
pero hasta las personas creen que
necesitas ser muy creativo para tener
flores y más que creatividad lo que
necesitas es conocerte saber qué formas
qué colores y qué olores son los que te
gustan y eso es lo que vas a traer a tu
vida en realidad solamente necesitas
unos frascos una jarra cualquier
recipiente donde colocar tus flores y
acomodarlas del lugar donde las vayas a
disfrutar
con esto se desmiente la idea de que
tener flores es una inversión cara
aprender a disfrutar una rosa es tan
gratificante como disfrutar de 100
entonces pues con todo esto que fui
descubriendo que fui observando quise
que más personas conocieran todo esto
sobre el mundo de las flores y diseñé el
reto floral alegra tu vida con flores se
trata de comprometerte durante cuatro
meses a siempre tener flores como parte
de tu decoración y porque cuatro meses
porque es el tiempo suficiente para que
vivas experimentes y sientas esta
energía de la que les he estado hablando
además en este tiempo alcanzas a vivir
un cambio de estaciones que es algo
hermoso
me encantó con todas las personas que me
escriben de todas partes del mundo para
compartir me cuánto ha cambiado su vida
desde que las flores son parte de ella y
así como a mi papá el día que no están
se dan cuenta
la subida no se siente igual
y es que no necesita ser un día especial
para tener flores deje el día especial
para tener más flores pero todos los
días debemos tener cosas lindas de
nuestra vida todos los días
merecemos sonreír y ser felices
entonces estaba yo el otro día ensayando
para la presentación de hoy con una
amiga que es doctora y cuando termino me
dice si anna yo quiero hacer el reto
floral me dado cuenta que mis pacientes
muchas veces están enojados son un poco
gruñón es y como no si tienen dolores
por eso vienen a visitarme entonces
estoy segura sí que si pongo flores en
la recepción de mi consultorio les voy a
regalar una sonrisa mientras esperan
entonces me voy a organizar y voy a ver
qué día puedo ir al distrito de las
flores para entonces comenzar el reto
floral yo le digo amiga me encanta tu
entusiasmo pero no necesitas organizarte
y ver qué día puedes ir al distrito de
las flores estoy segura que en el camino
de tu casa al consultorio hay muchos
establecimientos que venden flores
comienza hoy
y lo mismo que le dije ese día a mi
amiga se lo digo a ustedes comienza hoy
no te esperes encontrar el momento
hazlo parte de tu rutina integral oa tu
vida cotidiana
esta energía de la que les estaba
hablando se pone en movimiento genera un
efecto dominó con un crecimiento
expansivo y una vez que sientes esto no
quieres que se detenga
[Aplausos]
[Música]